from the company who has the rights to
Godzilla King Kong and Pacific Rim so
please please please do a crossover
where they all fight each other and
stuff comes the best American Godzilla
movie ever made which really isn't
saying much that's a lot of fish
Godzilla prepare for a movie that was
sold as a face-off between Walter White
and Godzilla yet barely contains any
Bryan Cranston and even less Godzilla
seriously there's less than 20 minutes
are we counted get ready for the tease
of the summer bringing you the king of
the monsters like you've never seen him
before
obscured by water hidden in smog barely
visible through masks shot from really
long distances on television and
shrouded in near constant darkness oh
wait here we go
ah in a movie called Godzilla spend 80%
of the run time with two monsters that
no one has ever heard of this gigantic
spider monkey thing and this moth who is
totally not Mothra then watch as they
fight against all odds to find a safe
place to orc
take that true love instead of watching
the title character kick-ass spend hours
of screen time with kick-ass and the
rest of his boring family there's his
dad whose wig is almost as bad as his
Japanese pension or be pissed so doc
honey would you dope who's gonna kick
asses wife an emergency room nurse who
reacts to a crisis by abandoning her
patients and pawning off her only child
on the co-worker and this guy he's a
professional bomb disposal expert who
never diffuses any bombs a magnet for
every single giant monster an eagle who
keeps volunteering for dangerous
missions instead of coming home to his
wife and kid if you don't walk out you
don't come back at all sir I'll do
whatever it takes and a hero who spends
more time and effort saving this random
boy he met on a train and he does trying
to save his own family but if it the
hustlers I sighs now I'm gonna get you
and Sam out tell them to run you idiot
in a nod to the series Japanese roots
right along with Ken Watanabe who's only
in the movie to dramatically say one
name recall him as you deliver one who
lied that they'll fight and of course
stare
starring the olsen triploids discount
Channing Tatum
bricen burg and real kite you have
curves Godzilla the good one man that's
what his breath is like I'd hate to see
his farts be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers in space no one can hear
you pee bacon pancakes welcome to
Jurassic Park I know you are but what
I'm I each set sold separately all you
have to do is be live